- Hi everyone, welcome to
the Homeroom livestream.
Today, we're actually just going to have
an "Ask Me Anything."
So any questions you have
for me about anything,
I encourage you to put below,
whether you're watching this
on Facebook or YouTube, put
this on the message board below,
and we have team members
who will look at it
and throw us those
questions about anything.
So please start doing that,
and now that I've given you a head start
on asking questions, I will
give my standard announcements.
We are not-for-profit, the only reason why
Khan Academy can even exist is because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I do wanna give a special shout out
to several corporations that stepped up,
especially as they saw
that we were already
running at a deficit
pre-COVID, and then with COVID,
our server cost went up.
We are trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs,
so special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, fastly and Novartis.
And that help has been a big deal,
but we are still running at a deficit.
And so any support, whether
you're a corporation
or you're just an individual, any amount
makes a huge difference
and allows us to reach
a lot more folks.
Another series of
announcements, I'll introduce
my colleague, Dan, that
some of you all have seen
before on the live stream.
Dan has some announcements as well.
- Hi everyone, thanks Sal.
So we have a couple of announcements
and reminders for everyone for this week.
So today we just-
we recognize that summer's different
from the regular school year,
so we created a playlist
of recommended activities,
covering Math, Language,
Arts and Creativity.
And in the Math section, I
just wanna call out two things.
First Camp Khan as well as
Get Ready for Grade Level Courses.
So as a reminder, that we launched
the Get Ready For Grade
Level Courses this week,
and each of those Math
courses will contain
the most important pre-requisite skills
for that particular grade.
And we know you have a
limited amount of time
so the intent is really
to provide learners
with the most efficient way to engage
with their upcoming grade level work
and wrapping the Get Ready
For Grade Level Courses
is Camp Khan.
So Camp Khan launched this Monday
as a reminder it's our virtual
summer camp that kicked off
and it will run through the end of August.
Camp Khan helps students
prepare for Math in the fall
with those Get Ready
For Grade Level Courses
and Camp Khan was designed to build habits
and mindsets for learning.
And we were really intentional
about making it fun for the summer.
And so if you wanna learn
more, there's a parent webinar
all about Camp Khan tomorrow
at four o'clock to 4:30 PST,
7 o'clock Eastern Time.
So please join us if you wanna learn more.
So those are the
announcements for this week.
Thanks Sal.
- Great, thanks Dan.
And I'll just doubly underline
some of what Dan just mentioned.
Obviously we had Lindsey on Monday
talking about the Get Ready
For Grade Level Courses.
We're really excited about
this because in any summer,
a lot of students need,
you know, have gaps
that they need to fill in to be ready,
and this is going to be a
summer, an extended summer
where many, many more students
are going to need that help.
And so whether you're a
student, a parent or a teacher,
this is a great way for
students to get ready
for grade level work and
make sure they have no
Swiss cheese gaps going into it.
And then Camp Khan, as Dan
just mentioned is a great way
of making it even more interactive and fun
and having a whole layer
of programs and fun
on top of the Get Ready
For Grade Level Courses.
So definitely check those things out.
So with that, I'm happy
to take some questions,
looks like the questions
have already come in.
Let's see from YouTube, Aya A says,
"Hi Sal, do you know how
schools expect to open
with COVID-19, if they do,
how will they do it safely,
and if they don't, how can
they make sure we're learning?
Thank you."
Well, Aya A, I think what
you're referring to is...
I think we talked to a lot
of district superintendents
and principals and teachers,
and I think everyone
is really struggling with it
because I think even two
weeks ago before COVID-19
started to pick again
and it does look like
it's picking up again in
much of the US at least,
people were thinking that,
'All right, we're going
to have to do some type of
socially distanced shift-based
model for back to school
where half the kids come
on say Monday and Wednesday
and the other half come
on Tuesday and Thursday,
or maybe the high school
students don't come to school
and do everything virtually
and then they use that
real estate for the middle
and elementary school
so that people can become
more socially distant,
also do shift-based with the teacher."
So this is really complex thing
that people were thinking about,
and even before the pickup in COVID,
people were also expecting
a potential pickup in COVID.
So you might have to
virtualize really fast
or go to Hybrid learning,
or even if you are able to show up,
there might be a subset of kids
whose families don't feel comfortable
sending them to school.
So you're gonna have to
have some virtual model.
What I'm hearing right
now, and this is, you know,
a few days old, it might change
based on the epidemiological statistics
of how far COVID's spread is.
People are definitely focused
on the younger students,
'cause I think that's where, frankly,
the child care issue is
super difficult for a lot of families.
I think in areas where they can,
people are thinking very
seriously about outdoors,
you know, we had Rachel
Skipper on yesterday
from Khan Lab School, and I
and her have been talking a lot
about how can we leverage, cordon off
some of the parking lot and
essentially have some hot spots,
and leverage that for outdoor play,
or even getting work done
for at least part of the day,
to make it a little bit more safer
and to get some social distancing.
But the simple answer is, I think people
are still struggling with can you do,
even from a physical spacing
epidemiological point of view.
And then once you get that
right, given how uncertain it is
the curricular point of
view is even more uncertain.
This is why at Khan Academy
we are trying our best
to help support schools,
teachers, parents and students.
You know, Dan's announcement about
the Get Ready for Grade Level
course, that's part of it,
to make sure that people are...
If they can use this over
the summer, that's great,
they'll be more ready for back to school,
but even if they don't
use it over the summer,
either the first couple
of weeks of back to school
could be focused on that
Get Ready for Grade Level,
because a lot of kids have been disengaged
for many months now.
Or as you go through the grade level work,
you can in parallel do the
Get Ready for Grade Level.
We're also working on learning plans.
Some of you all know several months ago
we had learning plans for
learning, especially math,
through the end of the
school year and the summer.
Now we wanna create learning plans
for starting back to school
through the school year.
So, expect to see those
in the next few weeks.
And we are actually working on a study
of what were the best
practices of schools during,
or districts during school closures,
and given the best practices before,
what are, kind of play books
for districts and schools
to think about hybrid
learning, where you're doing
some leveraging Khan Academy,
where kids are learning at
their own time and pace,
but you're also leveraging
synchronized sessions,
whether it's socially distanced
inside of the classroom
or synchronized sessions on
video conferencing of somehow,
and how can you do that well,
what are the best practices.
So, we're gonna try our
best to support teachers
and districts in this
situation, but you know,
the simple answer I have is
I think very few people really know
how this is going to evolve,
and it's a little scary
'cause we're only about eight weeks away,
and obviously if COVID keeps picking up,
we might be back into a lockdown scenario
in a couple of weeks.
That isn't that different than what we saw
in March and April and May.
So, we're trying to do the
most on our side to help out,
but it's gonna be tough and
uncertain for a lot of folks.
So, let's see, from
YouTube, Osama Al-Sadi says,
"Sal, do you have any plans
on improving your site
and making new versions of
videos with better quality,
and making new techniques for teaching,
or making online paid courses
for example using Zoom?"
Great question.
So, the simple answers are yes!
We're constantly thinking
about how to improve the site,
and Khan Academy, you
know, we're over 200 folks.
And I know some of you are gonna say,
"200 folks!
You know, that's a lot, we
can do a lot with that."
But I remind folks, we're the
budget of a large high school
and we're trying to, we have
107 million registered users,
and we have 80, 90 million
minutes of learning per day
during the school year, during week days.
So, we're trying to do a lot, we cover...
We have Khan Academy
Kids at the pre-K level,
which covers math, reading, writing,
social-emotional learning.
And then math, obviously,
we keep going all the way
to early college.
Then we have the sciences
at the high school
and early college level,
we're adding English language,
Arts, we have test prep, so
there's a lot of dimensions
that we're working on.
But we have a steady
pipeline of improvements.
Some of them aren't as obvious,
we're doing a major
infrastructure re-haul right now,
which won't change your
user experience other than
it will hopefully make
the site faster for you
and more performant and
more reliable for you,
and that also it'll make it easier for us
to develop new features.
Now, on the features side
we're constantly thinking about
how do we change the user experience
so that it is more engaging,
so that it's more effective.
And so, you ask a lot about videos,
so, I have a list of videos
that I'm either re-doing
or new videos to cover certain topics
where it seems like we still have gaps.
We have a whole content team
that's constantly adding
and revising exercises, and
we have a large engineering
and product team,
designers, product managers,
to think about both the back-end,
how do we make the
infrastructure more scalable
as we're trying to serve so many people,
and the front-end, which
in kind of tech-speak is
the user experience side of things,
how do we make it more engaging.
And so, you see things like this
Get Ready for Grade Level courses,
that's more on the context side,
we're doing these learning plans,
that's kind of on the
content school-partnership
side of things.
And for this back to school
we're going to have things,
you know we're gonna
bring back several reports
that teachers have been asking
or improve those reports.
And then I hope a few months
after that, you'll start seeing
some navigational
improvements on the site.
So there's a lot that we're
trying to juggle all right now.
And I just kinda glazed
over the tip of the iceberg
of what's going on.
So Facebook, Carol Smith Capper says,
"Sal do you have any
recommendation for older students
who are supposed to be spending the summer
doing internships?
Since they have all been canceled."
I do have advice and I
don't know how good it is,
so take it or leave it, so to speak.
But I've been telling
this to any young person
who's in that situation.
I think there's a ton
of opportunity right now
to do really interesting things
that can help a lot of folks.
There could be simple
things of supporting people
who live alone, especially elderly people,
who might be feeling
very isolated right now
in times of COVID and
helping them get tech access
or through tech access, making
sure that they have someone
to talk to, have someone to help them out
with the groceries and it would be for you
to figure out how to do that in kind of a
safe socially distance way.
I think there's a lot of
potentially the educators,
teachers, who could help using support,
especially as they are
trying to transition
to this hybrid model
and teach kids over Zoom
or whatever else.
Maybe you could be a teaching assistant
for them of some sort.
We have this project schoolhouse.world,
this is not a Khan Academy project,
it's more of a Sal project.
Maybe one day it will become
part of a Khan Academy project,
but it is this notion that on Khan Academy
you can learn at your own time,
pace, get practice feedback,
gain mechanics, teachers can monitor it.
There's videos and articles
to help unstick you
and hints on each of the exercises.
But a complete learning
experience would also involve
some form of synchronous
live human interaction,
where you can ask questions,
where you can ask questions
not only just from a teacher or a tutor,
but maybe also from peers.
And so this notion
about schoolhouse.world,
which is Mariah Austin is a volunteer,
who's been driving
this, and I've one of my
buddies from college his
name's Shishir Mehrotra
runs a company called Coda.io,
they essentially volunteered their time
to build the schoolhouse.world,
so that it can match tutors
and students who need help,
so that you can volunteer to be a tutor.
But interestingly, right now
it's a social engineering experiment
that we're doing right now.
We have more tutors and less demand.
So if anyone has questions and
especially high school math,
go to schoolhouse.world right now,
there's a little registration form
and then we let people in.
So we're at this unusual
situation right now
where there's some a lot of
amazing people who are hungry
to tutor people for free as volunteers,
and we're looking for more
students who need that tutoring.
So definitely go to schoolhouse.world,
whether you want to be a tutor
or whether you want to learn something.
I could imagine, there's a bunch of other,
it might not even be
related to COVID right now,
but this is a great time
on Zoom to start a podcast
or an interview series on a
topic that you find interesting.
And a lot of folks have more
time on their hands right now
because they're at home
and they're not traveling
and all of that.
So you'd be surprised you
could reach out to folks
and have interesting
conversations with them.
I think it's interesting,
this is a family project.
Get on Zoom with family
members all over the country
or the world and record
your family history.
That's not gonna be the type of internship
that's gonna pay you, but I actually think
it's pretty cool just to have...
If you think about it, if
your house is burning down,
God forbid, the thing that you're gonna
try to leave the house
with are your pictures
and all your family memories.
And one thing that I've been trying to do
is videotape family members,
especially older family members
and ask them about their life history,
ask them about their childhood,
ask them about their journeys of life,
the struggles, I get them on
video, you can record, Zoom,
and Google Hangouts and all that.
So I think that could also be
another interesting project.
But there's tons of opportunity I think,
to focus on whatever topic
is interesting to you.
So let's see Adnan Kanchwala says,
"Sir, you make all the
subjects very interesting."
Thanks Adnan I appreciate that.
"How did you find your love
for a particular subject?"
Well, if your question is,
how do I find the love for all subjects is
because I do generally believe
all subjects are interesting.
I've said this multiple
times on the live stream,
that sometimes students feel like,
"Oh, I gotta learn this
subject, I guess, I'll do it,
what on the tests."
We have to realize that
knowledge that you get to learn,
Well, first of all, it's a luxury.
If you think about like
human history, it's a luxury
to be able to dedicate years of your life
for the pursuit of learning.
Most of human history, most human beings
did not have that luxury.
And that the learning that
we now have access to,
we have access to the
total of human knowledge
or most of it up until this point.
And many very smart folks
would have done anything
to have access to the knowledge
that you now have access to.
Now I do think sometimes
textbooks and some courses
don't do the best job of reminding folks
how exciting this
knowledge is and hopefully
Khan Academy, at least, sometimes
if I'm making the video,
you hear it even in my voice
that I'm excited about it,
there's something interesting here.
But I would remind yourself
about that in particular.
If your question is, how
did I find the path in life?
How did I decide what to focus on,
given that I somehow found
every subject interesting?
I mean, I used to say in college
if there was something
called a PhD in everything,
I would've tried to get that PhD,
'cause I really enjoyed learning about
a lot of varied things and
try to draw a connection
between them.
But for me, it was a combination
of I had a lot of debt,
my family was not very wealthy.
So when I was 21 years old,
I was like, okay, let me do something
that I find really interesting
that I think I've developed
some really good skills at
that can also help pay off debt,
even help to support my family.
And so this was in, I
graduated in 1998 from college
and from a Master's program
in Computer Science.
So it was a great time, and it frankly
is even a better time now in that field.
But as I went into that path,
you know, I actually just gave
a few graduation addresses,
and what I've told everyone
is when you're young,
you often say, "Oh, do I pick
this major or that major?
Do I pick that job or that job?"
And ask a lot of people,
make the best informed decision you can.
But there's no such thing as
the perfect decision there,
there's no such thing as the perfect path.
What matters more is the
energy and the attitude
that you bring to that path.
So whatever it is.
So I happened, my first job
while I was product manager
at Oracle, which is a big
kind of database enterprise
software company.
And my boss told me,
"Look, Sal, it's easy to
sometimes get cynical at a big company
you feel you're kind of a
small cog in a big machine."
But he's, like, "Just make
every day better than the last."
How are you making yourself better?
How are you making the
people around you better?
Constantly be asking questions,
constantly looking
around for opportunities
for you to make a difference,
whether it's at work or at home.
And then my boss, after business school,
I worked at a Hedge Fund.
So as you can tell, I've done
my share of career changes,
he reminded me that it's
super important as an investor
to have time to pursue your
passions and develop interests,
because it'll allow you to
see the world in new ways
that other people participating
into the stock market
do not, and so you might be able to see
an interesting investment before others.
And it also is just a way to recharge
and make sure that you're not making
a bunch of bad decisions,
but more likely making
a few good decisions.
So that's my best advice.
Pick a path, ask a lot of questions,
and, you know, you don't
have to be embarrassed
about even asking about
very practical things,
about how much money do you make,
what are the work hours,
what are the benefits?
But also this is going to be a job
that I can enjoy doing,
that I'm not going to be miserable doing.
And then once you find that path,
make sure you have space for your passion.
And then you have this positive attitude
towards both the job and
what you're able to do
outside of your work.
And the last thing I would
say, don't define yourself
entirely by your work.
I think in our society we kind of define
who we are as people by our work,
and then that creates
this kind of weird stress,
and almost, it creates
unsatisfaction with work
because you're looking for
almost too much meaning
out of your work, where
you could a lot of meaning
in other things in life.
Let's see, good question, though.
So Rylan Reid says, "I've used
Khan Academy for five years,
and I have to say thank you-"
Thank you Rylan for thanking us.
"What is going to be your next update?
What course or part of the
website are you most proud of?
Thank you so much."
Well, we've talked about
some of the updates,
things like the Get Ready
for Grade Level courses.
Expect to see things
like learning plans soon.
We're constantly iterating and
tweaking all of the content
across the site.
There's gonna be some teacher tools
that are gonna get
updated in the next few,
actually, in time for back to school.
We have some plans that are
probably about six months away,
don't hold me to it, 'cause
there's still a lot going on,
where we wanna improve the
navigation around course mastery
and things like that.
Those are the big ones.
I mean, there's definitely
more subject areas
that we wanna improve on,
so yeah, there's a lot.
Let's see, from YouTube,
Sohana Anaya says,
"I get forget math I've
practiced before very easily,
and it's hard to remember
again in practice,
how to remember it again in practice.
So what should I do to never forget them?"
Well, Sohana, my best advice,
and this is actually
backed up by research,
is this notion of spaced repetition,
which Khan Academy tries to do,
which is, when you learn something,
there's kind of a forgetting curve,
that over time, your likelihood
of being able to know it
diminishes over time.
But if after some degradation,
you go and review that thing again,
the probability is that it gets
back to where it was before,
and now this time, because
of that space repetition,
your degradation curve is slower.
And so then, after say twice
as long, you review it again,
then your degradation
curve will be even slower.
So my best advice to you would be
one, if you can create
a consistent practice,
say even 15, 20 minutes a day,
say three, four or five
days a week on Khan Academy,
if you can make that a habit
just like brushing your teeth
or making your bed, which
I also highly recommend,
then I think it's much less likely
that these skills will atrophy
and that you will forget so to speak.
And we have things like mastery challenges
that make you review things,
do that space repetition.
And we have things like course
challenges and unit tests.
The other thing I would say
is when you're learning,
especially math, sometimes
there's this tendency
to memorize formulas and just say,
"Okay, what steps do I need to
do to get the right answer?"
That might work in the
short term sometimes,
and that'll work less and less
as you get into more
and more advanced math,
what's far more helpful is to think about,
"Why does it work?
Why does it make sense?"
That algebraic step it's
not some magic incantation.
Why does it make sense that
you have to add the same thing
to both sides of an equation?
While two things were equal before,
if you do something to
only one side of it,
if you change the value of only one side,
they can't be equal anymore.
So you have to change
the value in the same way
to both sides, so always
connect these dots.
But what you'll find is
all of math is connected.
And if you do that,
especially with more of
the foundational skills,
you're gonna find that
the more advanced skills
almost become intuitive.
You're gonna be like,
"Well, why does someone
even have to tell me this?
This is obvious."
So I highly recommend,
do the space repetition
and really sit and think and ponder
why something in math makes sense
and how it connects to
other things you know.
And what I just said,
actually, isn't just math,
this applies frankly to almost any field
you're trying to study.
So let's see, Rude Rainelle
Mandel from Facebook says,
"How do you deal with
social media negativity?"
It's a good question and I've
said on this forum before
that I do things like meditation
and how it's kind of
like Rain-X for the mind,
for your emotions.
Rain X, if you don't know, it's this thing
that you can wipe onto your windshield
and that when it rains,
the water just beads up
and washes off.
You almost don't even
need a windshield wiper
if you put that chemical.
I don't know if the chemical
is good for you or not,
but it does wonders for beading up water.
But I've always said
things like meditation
are kind of like Rain X for your mind,
because obviously if someone
says something to you
that you disagree with,
or says, you're like this,
or is making a generalization about you
or say something negative,
we all have an ego of different sizes
that immediately wants to react to that.
That immediately says, "I
can't believe they said that."
"I can't believe they
think that about me."
"Don't they know that I'm this, this, that
or I'm a good person."
We all have these internal
voices, which is really our ego.
And when you meditate, you
realize you are not your ego,
you are not that little voice
that's always trying to defend itself.
And then you can let these
things go a little bit more.
It identifies your awareness
less with your persona.
You're like, "You know what?
They're criticizing this thing
that they perceive called Sal or whatever,
but I am not that,
and really, should I get
that worked up about it?
One day the sun will absorb the earth
and the universe will
experience kind of a heat death.
Is this really that big of a deal?"
With that said, it does
hit you every now and then,
and we're lucky at Khan Academy
because we are, I believe,
doing a positive social thing
that most of the feedback
we get is positive, but we do
get critiques and criticisms
and every now and then I get an email,
at one of my email
addresses at Khan email,
which I do look at, which
are kind of angry sometimes.
I suspect maybe a student
feels a little frustrated
with the mastery mechanics or something.
And they'll sometimes even use expletives,
which I read those things.
And it doesn't feel great,
but I just remind myself
that it's not really
going at you directly,
it's going at someone's
conception of what they think
is some type of an organization.
And I think it's much easier for people
to be a little bit mean to what they think
is an abstract organization
than to another human being.
But yeah, so bottom line, meditate,
try not to take that seriously,
recognize that what folks
say about you on social media
or anywhere else really isn't
defining of who you are.
Let's see, so Michele Marie
Moussaoui says from Facebook,
"Any advice on how to help
kids with math anxiety?"
So I'm not a psychologist,
so take what I'm about to do
with a grain of salt.
But I saw this even in the early days
when I was tutoring my cousins.
I think there's something very powerful
about building a habit, and
then as you build a habit
and say, work on Khan Academy,
and you start building some confidence,
especially over the summer
for students able to work
on Khan Academy, even 20 minutes a day,
there's not the stresses of,
"Oh, I have to get the
homework done by tomorrow."
Or "How am I going to
perform on the exam."
Or I wanna make sure that I
get an A or B in the class."
None of those anxieties are there.
So it's really you're just
doing it the way that you might,
you know, learn a musical
instrument or practice a sport.
And so, that I think in of itself,
starts to reduce anxieties
and as the students practice
in a kind of a deliberate
habit forming way
that they will gain more confidence.
And I recommend using the
Get ready for grade level courses,
or even start at kids, even if they're,
a later elementary school
or middle school student,
start them at early learning or start them
in their arithmetic score
and arithmetic course,
so they can review some of those basics
and build that confidence
and then they'll fill to it,
they'll learn all their Swiss Cheese gaps,
which is another source
of lack of confidence,
so that when they get to
their grade level or beyond,
they feel a lot more confident.
The other thing is, I think
it's reminding student
just a little bit of that
meditation conversation I did,
they actually even a minute
or two of meditation,
which is really just sitting silently,
and letting your thoughts
get as still as possible,
I think is really powerful
for any type of anxiety.
I've said it on this forum before,
I've never really enjoyed planes,
I get kind of claustrophobic on planes.
It's like a real thing for me.
And I just remind myself,
"Look Sal, that anxiety circuit
in your brain that's starting
to cycle that's not you."
And once you can kind of just observe that
it starts to slow down and you're like,
"Hey, I'm not this thing,
that anxious about this plane,
and it is what it is,
the dice has been cast."
It serves no one for me
to be miserable about this
and I think even with young
kids, when you talk about that.
And we talk about things
like growth mindset,
that look, it's not about
whether you get it right
or get it wrong, it's all about the effort
that you put into it.
It's not about whether
you're, "smart" or "not smart"
I'd argue that's not the thing.
It's about how much are
you willing to persevere
and have resiliency and when
you get something wrong,
learn from those mistakes.
And that's actually when
your brain grows the most.
Let's see,
Other, there's a lot
of good questions here.
So Susanna Garcia Domingos,
one of our regulars
on the live stream good
to see you Susanna,
hopefully one day we'll meet in person,
I feel like I know since you
ask so many good questions.
"What are some of your favorite movies?"
And I think I've answered
that in a previous
Ask Me Anything.
I will say, you know, we
have Francis Ford Coppola
on a couple of about two weeks ago,
and I'm not usually a fan of bloody movies
and violent movies, I'm
actually, I'm pretty,
I guess you could say soft that way.
I'm usually a fan of like
Pixar and things like that.
But "The Godfather" is one
of the top movies of all time
and so that's why it was
pretty cool to have Francis on.
I think "Gandhi" is
definitely one of my favorite,
when I was in college I used to organize
an annual viewing of "Gandhi"
so that's also one of
my top favorite movies.
I will say "Star Wars" you know,
episode four the original
one and the newer "Star Wars"
feels like it's a little
bit of a business now
where they keep kind of going
through the same plot line.
And so it's kind of, I
don't know, you know,
the plot line seems to be over and over,
someone who needs to
discover their potential
and struggle with the dark forest
while the Empire is building some device
that can kill planets.
I think they're reusing that
plot a little bit too much.
So the new "Star Wars"
in some ways, kind of,
making the original "Star
Wars" feel derivative,
even though it's the other way around.
But "Star Wars" definitely is one of my
all time favorite movies.
Let's see other favorite movies,
I could probably think of
others, but those are the three
that are coming...
And "The Matrix", "The Matrix" is,
I remember when "The Matrix" came out.
I believe it was the summer of 1998
I had just I graduated from college
and everyone was excited about
the new "Star Wars" movies
that were going to come out,
the prequels that were gonna come out
at the end of that summer.
And myself and a couple of friends
we were just bored one
Friday, and we're like,
"Well, there's this
movie with "The Matrix",
it's got Keanu Reeves, you
know, maybe it's like "Speed"
or something like that, and we went
with fairly low expectations,
but we were blown away.
So I'd say "The Matrix"
is a pretty good movie.
And actually, "The Matrix"
is in a strange way,
it's really connected to
these notions of meditation
and what is reality anyway, and
should we get too caught up,
Or, you know, to some degree...
By definition, your mind has
constructed this the reality.
Now, we all believe that
there's a true reality
outside of our mind
that's informing our mind
as we construct that reality.
But "The Matrix" definitely
plays around with those ideas,
I think, in a pretty effective way.
So let's see, other questions.
So Rubik's Nerd from YouTube says,
"Can you please explain
Advanced Quadratics."
This is probably not the
right place to do it,
but we do have a lot of content
on advanced quadratics on Khan Academy.
I would go to Algebra II, and look at
the factoring quadratics
or solving quadratics,
or solving quadratic equations
on our Algebra II content,
and maybe some of our
pre-calculus content as well,
if you're looking at advanced quadratics.
So, that's the best, we
probably have 20 or 30 videos
and exercises just on
the topic of quadratics.
So, let's see we're almost out of time,
but I really enjoy doing this.
Let's see, other questions.
So, actually this is an
interesting one from Facebook,
Mehran Ararat says,
"Hey Sal, what is your opinion about IQ,
Intelligence Quotient?"
I am skeptical of it.
I think you can have a
test with logic puzzles,
and it will measure
capability in that dimension.
It will measure your
capability at that moment
in doing logic puzzles.
But, the problem I have
with IQ tests is that,
they'll say they'll use that,
how you happened to perform
on those logic puzzles or
whatever they're making you do.
At that moment and they'll
make some generalizations
on your innate ability or
how that might carry over
to all walks of life.
And I think that just,
you're overgeneralizing
at that point.
For example, I think you
could take almost anyone
and if you give them practice solving
the types of logic puzzles
that you see on IQ tests,
their IQ will increase, which
tells you that the IQ is not,
their measured IQ would increase
according to those tests.
And I know plenty of people
who, in that dimension of IQ,
could do very well or
might not do so well,
but in other dimensions
that I think any of us
would consider a sign of intelligence,
or sign of critical thinking
capability are amazing.
I know some people who are amazing,
they're amazingly funny or observant,
or amazing public
speakers or storytellers,
which I would say for me
it's almost the purist,
someone is good at those things,
that's kind of a raw form of intelligence.
But, because of background or exposure,
or just interest has never kind of gotten
to the whole logic puzzles,
which tend to show up in IQ tests.
So yeah, they're interesting.
I've taken them every now
and then, they're fun.
I've been one of those
people who've been lucky
to be good at those things.
So, when I was young, I remember,
I think it was second grade, I remember,
some kind of a psychiatrist
sitting with me
for like three hours giving
me a bunch of IQ tests.
And then that helped me kind of get into,
the school gave me more
attention, which was amazing.
I was lucky, but I'm
suspicious of that test,
'cause there's other kids
that probably had at least
as much potential that probably didn't,
that wasn't their thing.
So, let's see other,
maybe we're out of time,
but this is maybe, are there
any other last questions
that maybe to finish off in.
Actually, this is an interesting
question from YouTube,
Adeline (indistinct) says,
"Hello, Sal, right now I'm learning that
all the Ivy League schools
aren't requiring the SAT,
what then can you enter with?"
So Adelaide, good question.
So first of all, if they're
making the SAT optional,
or the SAT or the SAT and ACT optional,
doesn't mean that they're not
going to consider the SAT.
I think the reason why they're doing that,
especially this year
is because with COVID,
access to taking some tests
might be a little bit more difficult,
but University of Chicago
and we had Jim Nondorf
on this Homeroom a couple of months ago.
They famously went testing optional,
but still 90% of the students applying
submit some form of SAT or ACT scores.
So, the university is for sure
going to still consider it.
And they do view it as something,
once again they don't use your SAT scores
defining of who you
are, but they view that
in conjunction with your
grades, your extracurriculars,
your essays, your
recommendation as something
that altogether can help
predict your college readiness
and your longterm potential.
So, if you're in a position to
take something like the SAT,
highly recommend to do it.
Now, another thing I was
talking to Jim Nondorf about,
this was kind of off camera, is he said,
"Look, I would be
interested if kids can show
that they've mastered
courses on Khan Academy,
because not only does that show
that they've know the material,
but it also shows that they had the agency
and they had the drive on their
own to learn the material."
And so, I highly recommend
if you are thinking
about going to selective universities,
get mastery at your own time, pace,
summer is a great time to do it,
especially for some of you
had your internships canceled
and use that time to master as
many of the advanced courses
as you can on Khan Academy.
Calculus, Statistics,
Physics, Chemistry, Biology,
Economics, American history, Civics.
These are all things that we have
at a senior or even early college level.
And if you can get 90%
mastery on Khan Academy,
or a 100% mastery, take a screenshot,
and send it in with your
college applications.
I think, the colleges
will take that seriously
and also tell them why you did that.
'cause you have drive,
you have initiative.
That's all the colleges
are really looking for.
They're looking for good
people who are interesting,
who wanna help the
world, who have the drive
and the intellectual
capability, and the discipline
to fulfill those ambitions
at some point in their life
and also contribute to a diverse
kind of engaging community
on campus.
So, that's my best advice there.
So, we're all out of time.
This is super fun.
We'll we'll do this again.
And thanks everyone for joining.